[Musik]
wie soll jetzt dieses Finanzloch
gestopft werden über Steuern über andere
Einnahmen auf jeden Fall kann nicht die
Transformation der Wirtschaft daran
schid also ich bin dafür die
Schuldenbremse zu lockern wenn diese
Gelder die ja tatsächlich da sind ne
nicht für die Umwelt genutzt werden wir
haben nur diese Umwelt weitere Kürzungen
könen nur
äh Schaden
äh verursachen ich hoffe einfach dass
die Herrschaften in der Politik da eine
Lösung
verfinden und damit herzlich willkommen
zu diesem ZDF
Spezial wieso hat der
Bundesfinanzminister gestern am späten
Abend den Haushalt gesperrt das gab es
noch nie in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik und was heißt das
überhaupt Haushaltssperre welche Folgen
hat das klär wir jetzt und dafür
verschieben sich die rosenheimkops um 12
Minuten
starten wir mit der guten Nachricht es
ist noch Geld da aber die schlechte
Nachricht folgt zugleich es ist deutlich
weniger und dadurch ist offen was noch
bezahlt werden kann wird ihr Strompreis
ihr Gaspreis noch gedeckelt sollten
Energiepreise im Winter plötzlich wieder
doch in exorbitante Höhen schnellen und
steht die Bahn bald dauerhaft still weil
marode schien nicht mehr gefflickt
werden können wo kann der Staat noch mit
Geld reingehen fördern beruhigen und wo
nicht mehr Frank bufald erklärt was es
mit der Haushalt spre auf sich
hat noch so ein Paukenschlag diesmal aus
dem Finanzministerium Haushaltssperre
kurz und knapp heißt es da alle
Verpflichtungsermächtigungen sein mit
sofortiger Wirkung zu sperren eine
E-Mail die es in sich hat es ist ein
scharfes Schwert es darf jetzt nichts
mehr ausgegeben werden ohne dass das
Bundesfinanzministerium noch mal drauf
guckt damit keine Verpflichtung für die
Zukunft eingegangen werden die
möglicherweise nicht mehr gedeckt sind
viele Subventionen etwa für den den
klimaneutralen Umbau der Stahlindustrie
oder der Stromerzeugung stehen damit auf
der Kippe der Vizekanzler etwas
konsterniert das ist der sozusagen der
Beginn einer gewissen Kettenreaktion
dass diese Gelder nicht ein Add On sind
auf das man leichtfertig verzichten kann
sondern tatsächlich Gelder sind die
Transformation und Innovation und
Investition in die deutsche Wirtschaft
auslösen bzw unterstützen das gilt auch
für den Ausbau der Infrastruktur etwa
bei der Bahn oder dem Ersatz für Brücken
bereits zugesagte Verpflichtungen aber
sind nicht betroffen wir haben kein
shutdown ähnlich wie wir das aus den USA
können in irgendeiner Form aber es heißt
auch neue Verpflichtungen können dann
nicht oder nur unter besonderen
Voraussetzungen eingegangen werden
unklar was aus den Milliarden
Subventionen für neue Projekte wird etwa
der geplanten Chipfabrik bei Magdeburg
da aber gibt der Kanzler sich
zuversichtlich auch für die
halbleiterfabriken die uns allen so am
Herzen liegen mir ganz besonders
gilt das Gleiche der Teil des
privatwirtschaftlichen Investments ist
deutlich größer als das was wir dazu
beizutragen haben mehr privates Kapital
statt Geld vom Staat diese Hoffnung
bleibt größere Subventionen auf Pump
verhindert schon die Schuldenbremse im
Grundgesetz das definiert ja eine
Obergrenze für die sogenannte
Nettokreditaufnahme insofern ist der
Haushalt ganz offen nicht
verfassungsgemäß wenn der jetzt
verabschiedet würde auch in diesem Fall
aber stündet Deutschland nicht still
vorläufige Haushaltsführung hieße es
dann Geld wäre da nur eben nicht für
neue große
Pläne Haushalt gesperrt wie weiter dazu
hat heute professor Michael Hüter
Direktor des Instituts der deutschen
Wirtschaft den Bundestag beraten
nominiert von den Grünen jetzt steht der
uns Rede und Antwort schönen guten Abend
Herr Professor Hüter schönen guten Abend
was haben Sie denn heute im Bundestag
geraten nun ich habe darauf hingewiesen
dass die Unsicherheit die jetzt
unvermeidbar ist für uns alle natürlich
erhebliche volkswirtschaftliche
Konsequenzen hat das betrifft die
privaten Haushalte sie haben es erwähnt
eben in dem Einspieler mit der Strom und
gaspreisbremse die in Frage steht es
betrifft vor alleningen die Unternehmen
die ohnehin einer schwierigen Situation
sind sie haben eine große Transformation
zu leisten in zur Klimaneutralität dafür
sind Rahmenbedingen des Staates zu
setzen und diese Dinge stehen nun alle
in Frage ob es der Kompromiss zur
stromsteuerabsenkung und des
Spitzenausgleichs für die
energieintensiven ist oder ob es Fragen
sind wie die Investition im Einzelnen
stattfinden bis zu Infrastruktur und
dieses Maß an Unsicherheit ist das
schlimmste was man in solchen Phase
haben kann deswegen zwar alles sauber
und ordentlich zu machen Bundeskanzler
daruf hingewiesen aber wir haben nicht
allzu viel Zeit und ihr konkreter Rat
nun die Frage ist ja sind die Ausgaben
an sich noch berechtigt die sind ja
nicht in Frage gestellt worden der Klima
und transformationsfah eine wichtige
Aufgabe er soll aus der Jährlichkeit
heraus eine solche Investitionsdynamik
entfalten für diese Transformation zu
Klimaneutralität dass das auch gelingt
bis 2045 wie es im Klimaschutzgesetz
steht und vom Verfassungsgericht ja auch
mit versehen als Testat versehen wurde
ich glaube dass kurzfristig das Beste
wäre diesen Fond analog dem Bundeswehr
Sondervermögen in den das Grundgesetz
einzubauen er beruht letztlich auch auf
einer
verfassungsgerichtsurteilssprechung und
insofern diese Aufgabe dahinzupacken
klare Perspektiven dafür und wir müssen
ansonsten fragen wie wir im normalen
Haushalt die Investitionen abbilden da
gibt es Reformbedarf den muss man
vielleicht nicht ganz kurzfristig
angehen aber eine investitionsklausel
für die Schuldenbremse ist aus meiner
Sicht etwas was zwingend hineingehört
das heißt sie sagen ganz klar das Geld
braucht es und wir brauchen eine
Grundgesetzänderung äh um weiter an
dieses Geld zu kommen wie lang ist denn
jetzt ganz konkret der aktuelle Haushalt
gesperrt nun zunächst einmal gilt die
haushaltsperre ja für die
Verpflichtungsermächtigung das heißt der
Haushalt 2023 wird soweit abgewickelt
aber auch der das ist heute in der
Anhörung deutlich geworden von den
Verfassungsjuristen hat ja keine
verfassungsqualität mehr einen neuen
Haushalt wird es erstmal nicht geben
nach Artikel 111 gilt die vorläufige
Haushaltsführung dann wird normal der
Haushalt in Gang gesetzt das heißt wir
haben Verwaltungshandeln das ist alles
notwendig und die Verpflichtungen die
man eingegangen ist wird man auch
bedienen können aber es entsteht nicht
mehr wir brauchen verlässliche
Rahmenbedingungen deswegen schon meine
Erwartung dass letztlich Regierung aber
ich glaube die Opposition muss hier mit
ins Boot denn es geht um die Verfassung
gemeinsam eine Lösung finden und alle
haben ein Interesse daran eine künftig
regierende jetzige Opposition will auch
das Problem gelöst haben jetzt
durchzuhuscheln sich durchzumogeln wird
nicht gehen also braucht man hier auch
einen breiten Konsens und dann muss man
richtige Lösung finden beispielsweise
mit einem Sondervermögen beispielsweise
mit einer investitionsklausel sie
fordern Verlässlichkeit aber natürlich
so eine Haushaltssperre sorgt ja erstmal
für maximale Unsicherheit war das denn
notwendig ja der Bundesfinanzminister
muss ja dieser Lage auch Rechnung tragen
es ist ja einfach unvermeidbar dass
jetzt erstmal viele Fragezeichen sich
ergeben haben es ist auch noch nicht
klar welche Folgen dass wir über den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond hat die
Verfassungsjuristen heute haben sehr
deutlich gemacht dass der ähnlich zu
behandeln ist wie der Klima und
transformationsfond von daher ist das
richtig das ist eine Vorsorge die er zu
leisten hat aber es macht umso klarer
und dringlicher dass wir hier eine sehr
grundsätzliche Lösung brauchen und dass
sich da alle gemeinsam auch den Kopf
drüber zu zerbrechen haben Unsicherheit
in unsicheren Zeiten Herr Professor
Hüter vielen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung
sehr gerne ja eine durch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht scharfgestellte
schuldenbrem stellt alles auf den Kopf
was nun fragen sich alle drei mögliche
Lösungen zeigen wir
jetzt aus Karlsruhe der
verfassungsrechtliche Hammer in Berlin
das finanzpolitische Dilemma 60
Milliarden Euro so groß ist das
plötzliche Haushaltsloch mindestens die
Optionen
begrenzt Möglichkeit 1 ein sogenannter
notlagebeschluss als Ausnahme zur
Schuldenbremse der Bundestag könnte für
das aktuelle Haushaltsjahr erneut eine
außergewöhnliche Nots feststellen
Stichwort Energiekrise und ukrainekrieg
mit einfacher Bundestagsmehrheit doch
die Hürden sind hoch ob das
Verfassungsgericht mitgehen würde
unsicher Möglichkeit 2 die
Schuldenbremse wird ganz ausgesetzt per
Grundgesetzänderung auch das eine Option
allerdings nur mit zwei Drittel Mehrheit
in Bundestag und Bundesrat dass sich
politische Mehrheiten hierfür finden
lassen
unwahrscheinlich bleibt noch ein harter
Sparkurs seit Tagen wird in der Ampel
darüber Disku mit welchen Einsparungen
sich ein so großes Finanzloch überhaupt
schließen lässt Kürzungen bei
klimaschädlichen Subventionen fordern
beispielsweise die Grünen Abstriche bei
der Kindergrundsicherung und dem
Bürgergeld die FDP so oder so für
spürbare Haushaltsentlastung müssten
deutlich mehr Bereiche angepackt werden
sparen die einzige Möglichkeit was
bedeutet das für die deutsche Wirtschaft
das kläre ich jetzt mit Jürgen Kerner
vichef der stahlgewerkschaft IG und im
Aufsichtsrat von tüssengrup man und
Siemens schönen guten Abend Herr
Kerner guten Abend Herr Kerner Haushalt
gesperrt Schuldenbremse scharf gestellt
vor welche konkreten Probleme stellt das
die deutsche
Wirtschaft ja die Auswirkungen können
massiv sein und zwar für die ganze
Industrie und damit natürlich auch für
den ganzen Standort Deutschland
mit diesen Entscheidung jetzt auch des
Verfassungsgerichtes wird ja nicht der
Klimaschutz in Frage gestellt sondern
die Klima Ziele werden und müssen
erreicht werden und die Frage ist
erreichen wir die Klimaziele indem wir
100.000 Industriearbeitsplätze umbauen
um Teil dieses Klimaschutzes zu sein
oder ob wir 100erttausende Arbeitsplätze
verlieren und damit im Endeffekt den
Wohlstand in diesem Land auf das Spiel
setzen um diese Frage geht es jetzt in
diesen Tagen schauen wir mal ganz
konkret auf tüssenrup Deutschlands
größter Stahlkonzern da ist ja der
Auftrag klar grüner stahlumstellung auf
klimaneutrale Produktion wieso schafft
das ein Konzern wie tüssenrup mit mehr
als 40 Milliarden Umsatz im vergangenen
Jahr nicht aus eigener
Kraft ja es gibt überhaupt kein
Stahlunternehmen momentan dass diesen
Umstieg aus eigener Kraft schaffen kann
wir müssen im Endeffekt erst einen Markt
für grünen Stahl schaffen grüner Stahl
hat die gleichen Eigenschaften wie
grauer Stahl nur die Herstellung ist
viel aufwendiger es muss sehr viel
investiert werden und deswegen brauchen
wir jetzt die staatliche Unterstützung
der Bundesregierung tüssengrup hat den
Vorteil dass wir einen rechtskräftigen
Bescheid haben um 25% der
Stahlproduktion umstellen zu können die
Bundesregierung auch das Land fördert
massiv aber viele andere
Stahlunternehmen in Deutschland z.B im
Saarland aber auch in Bremen
Eisenhüttenstadt und auch noch HKM in
Duisburg haben überhaupt noch keine
Zusagen und deswegen ist da wir deutlich
wenn wir den Umbau in eine grüne
Stahlindustrie wollen und die
Stahlarbeiter z.B bekennen sich zu
diesem Umbau in eine nachhaltige
klimaneutrale Stahlproduktion dann
brauchen wir die staatliche
Unterstützung um diese massiven
Investitionen zu schaffen und nach vorne
irgendwann muss ich das System selber
tragen dann müssen irgendwann auch mal
die die die letztendlich die Abnehmer
wie z.B die Autoindustrie einen
Aufschlag für grünen Stahl dann auch
bezahlen aber stand heute wäre das nicht
ohne staatliche Unterstützung machbar
diesen Umstieg zu organisieren sie
sprechen die festen Zusagen an können
sie sich da weiterhin drauf verlassen
dass dieses Geld auch fließen
wird ja der alle Experten sowohl unsere
Rechtsanwälte bei türsen Grup aber auch
die von Seiten der Bundesregierung
bestätigen dass ses Gitter und türsen
Grup letztendlich recht kräftige
Förderbescheide haben das Geld kommt die
Frage ist nur woher kommt's dann aber es
gibt den Anspruch auf dieses Geld wie
gesagt aber große Teile der Industrie
die auch diesen Umstieg brauchen die
stehen momentan vor einem schärbenhaufen
wo klar ist wir wollen umstärken ist ja
nicht nur die Stahlindustrie sondern
auch viele andere Bereiche und es gibt
aber keine Möglichkeit der
Finanzierung klar ist umgestellt soll
werden offen ist noch wie und vor allem
wie das finanziert wird vielen Dank für
diesen Einblick und die
Ausführung herzlichen Dank das Gespräch
haben wir kurz vor der Sendung
aufgezeichnet ja die Folgen der scharf
gestellten Schuldenbremse und der
Haushaltssperre sind immens so viel ist
klar unklar ist allerdings weiterhin wen
es wieh trifft das wird weiter
verhandelt in Berlin den neuesten Stand
haben dann für Sie unsere Kollegen vom
heutejournal um 21:30 Uhr heute in der
Halbzeitpause des Freundschaftsspiels
Österreich Deutschland ihnen vielen Dank
fürs Interesse bis hier und einen
schönen Abend
noch